[Music]
foreign
Ablaze
[Applause]
gunshots ringing out
cries from those watching on of death to
the dictator
[Applause]
[Music]
when there's so little information to go
on from Iran and so much at stake
moments like this carry outsides
importance depending on the
interpretation
a storming of the Bastille moment
or another Crackdown by authorities
Iranian officials were quick to claim
the situation was now calm State TV
today showing the aftermath they
insisted that the fire was started by
prisoners they called gangsters and
thugs not political detainees and
confirmed that there had been deaths
because of smoke inhalation
is
Evan prison is a touchstone in Iran both
for supporters and critics of the regime
Anna Diamond was detained there for 200
days most of it in solitary confinement
accused of Espionage you don't have a
bed you don't have a sink to wash your
hands face books none of that so it's
just you and your thoughts and and I
think what was quite interesting about
the layout of the cell is that it is
literally a box so when you stretch open
your hands you can touch what the walls
on each side it's this emblem where
um freedom freedom comes to die and not
just freedom but also ideas but ideas
are alive elsewhere in Iran and in full
voice
University students in a video that
emerged today chanting I am a free woman
[Applause]
it is now the second month of protests
they are louder than ever Tom Cheshire
Sky News